This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。百分之二。这就是有电梯可用时依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个光怪陆离的现代世界中，关于心理韧性、健身以及培养抗压能力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端蜕变成一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是数字“2”加“%”，在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方都可以找到。欢迎收听《回溯往事》播客。从1979年开始，对当时的我和我而言，那是一个极其重要的时刻。84年对我也意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·恩格斯。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着去理解我们是如何挺过来的。和我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家一起。比如讨论80年代的马克·拉蒙特·希尔。84年是一个疯狂的年份。确实是个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，再没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
在IHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方搜索并收听《回溯往事》。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？欢迎收听《艰难成长的必修课》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖姆斯。这个节目聚焦黑人群体的经历，进行那些在任何地方都觉得不太安全去坦诚相告的对话，但在这里，你是在和一位懂行的执照专业人士交流。有多少男人带着一套盔甲生活。这向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。但这并不意味着，仅仅因为你有这种能力，你就必须这样去做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难成长的必修课》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你曾两次伪造这份特定的测试报告，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个女同性恋。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这里是《爱之陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在Iheart radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱之陷阱》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们将探讨二十岁时的一些重大生活变化与转折，以及它们所代表的意义。
for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s.
关乎我们的心理。大家好。欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到本播客。新听友，老听友，无论你们身在世界的哪个角落。非常高兴能在这里迎来又一期节目，当然，我们要在这里剖析二十岁的心理学。
Guys, I'm nervous for today's episode. I really am because I think I am tackling my most controversial topic and my most controversial episode yet. So much so that I actually kind of went back and forth as to whether I wanted to do this episode for a few months now. Do I talk about the male loneliness epidemic as a woman? Or do I just leave it? Do I give my opinion?
伙计们，我对今天的节目感到紧张。真的如此，因为我觉得我正在处理我迄今为止最具争议的话题和最具争议的一集。以至于过去几个月我其实一直在犹豫，到底要不要做这一期节目。作为一名女性，我要谈论男性孤独流行病吗？还是说我干脆不管它？我要表达自己的观点吗？
Do I dive into the research? Or do I let someone else kind of tackle that dumpster fire? As of about a week ago, I had kind of decided that this topic was one that I, I wasn't going to discuss on the podcast. But then I had a conversation with my friend, Emily, we were in the car and we were discussing this for, I would say literally over an hour, all the different angles, the male friendship angle, the misogyny angle, the co-ed school angle, the historical angle. And just from a purely, a pure fascination point of view, like I could not resist
我要深入研究相关研究吗？还是让别人去收拾那个烂摊子？大约一周前，我其实已经决定这个话题是我不打算在播客里讨论的。但后来我和朋友艾米丽聊了聊，我们在车里讨论这件事，我觉得 literalmente（字面意思上）讨论了一个多小时，探讨了所有不同的角度，男性友谊的角度、厌女症的角度、男女同校的角度、历史的角度。纯粹从一种着迷的角度来看，我真的无法抗拒
doing this topic. I feel like my favorite episodes are the ones that are making a personal mark in my own life. This is one of those things. So today, we're going to do it. We're going to talk about the male loneliness epidemic, what it is, the ways it is very much valid, and also what it is not. Of course, whilst we do that, we're going to break it down through the lens of psychology. And we're going to use academic research, peer-reviewed studies as well as some anecdotal evidence as well, to really understand what is going on. I feel like this phenomenon is talked about so much online at the moment, but often in a very opinionated manner, in a way that can also quickly become very divisive. And trust me,
不做这个话题。我觉得我最喜欢的节目都是那些在我的个人生活中留下印记的节目。这就是其中之一。所以今天，我们要做了。我们要谈论男性孤独流行病，它是什么，它在很大程度上成立的原因，以及它不是什么。当然，在这样做的同时，我们将通过心理学的镜头来剖析它。我们将使用学术研究、同行评议的研究以及一些轶事证据，来真正理解发生了什么。我觉得这个现象目前在网上被谈论得太多了，但通常带有很强的偏见，而且往往很快就会变得极具分裂性。相信我，
I myself, have strong opinions about this. But I also think we need a clearer kind of bird's eye view of what's really going on societally. I will also say, if you equally have a strong opinion about this as I do, please come into this episode with an open mind. Just put your viewpoint aside for a second. And if you come out still firmly believing what you initially believed, share it below. In a kind, constructive way, share it below. This episode will probably not be the last time that I talk about this. So I am actually very happy to have my mind changed, to hear different perspectives, especially from my male listeners. But without further ado, let's get into the psychology of the male loneliness epidemic.
我本人对此也有强烈的观点。但我也认为，我们需要对社会上真正发生的事情有一个更清晰的“上帝视角”。我还要说的是，如果你和我一样对此有着强烈的看法，请带着开放的心态来听这一集。暂时把你的观点放在一边。如果你听完后依然坚信你最初的信念，请在下方分享。用一种亲切、建设性的方式在下方分享。这一期可能不是我最后一次谈论这个话题。所以我其实非常乐意改变我的想法，听取不同的观点，尤其是来自我男性听者的声音。但废话不多说，让我们进入男性孤独流行病的心理学。
So let me start off by giving a bit of an overview of what the male loneliness epidemic actually is, and more importantly, how it differs from the general loneliness epidemic that is afflicting many, if not all, people. Firstly, loneliness is not something that we can quickly dismiss in any form. Loneliness is brutal. not feeling supported or seen or loved can really strip a human being of their reason for being and a sense of meaning in the world, a sense of a sense that they matter, which we all need at the end of the day. And this, the sense that we don't matter, the sense that we are not supported is becoming more common than ever to the point that loneliness has been declared an international health emergency.
那么，首先让我概述一下什么是男性孤独流行病，更重要的是，它与困扰许多（如果不是所有人）人的普遍孤独流行病有什么不同。首先，孤独不是我们可以轻易忽视的任何形式的问题。孤独是残酷的。没有得到支持、被看见或被爱，真的会剥夺一个人的生存理由和在世界上的意义感，剥夺一种“自己很重要”的感觉，而归根结底，这是我们所有人所需要的。这种觉得自己不重要、觉得没有得到支持的感觉比以往任何时候都更加普遍，以至于孤独已被宣布为国际卫生紧急事件。
There have been serious health consequences linked back to the prolonged, experience of loneliness. There is one very infamous study that concluded that loneliness may be as bad and as dangerous for you as smoking a pack of cigarettes a day. I think we often think about loneliness as something that creeps up the older we get. But the worrying thing about the current state of loneliness is that it's impacting young people more than older generations with around 47% of people under the age of 35 saying they haven't made a new friend in the past 12 months, and 30% of them saying that they wouldn't know how to. And since we typically thought that this younger generation was perhaps more immune to it than older generations, this is why, and this is
长期的孤独经历已经与严重的健康后果挂钩。曾有一个非常著名的研究得出结论：孤独对你的危害和危险程度，可能相当于一天抽一包烟。我想我们经常把孤独视为随着年龄增长而悄然逼近的东西。但关于目前孤独状况最令人担忧的是，它对年轻人的冲击超过了老一辈，大约47%的35岁以下的人表示他们在过去12个月里没有结交新朋友，其中30%的人表示他们不知道该如何结交。既然我们通常认为年轻一代或许比老一辈更能免疫孤独，这就是为什么，而且这也是
what, has people very, very worried. So I talked about this in my book, in my chapter on loneliness. It's actually my favorite chapter in my book, but the biggest factors contributing to this are things like technology. A study from Harvard actually found that 73% of those surveyed felt that technology, specifically social media, was contributing to a state of loneliness for them. Specifically, it is promoting something that we call social snacking, where because of social media and its accessibility, we get these kind of like bite-sized interactions with people, none of which are truly nourishing, but they like kind of semi-sustain us until we get to a point where we realize that we are very nutrient deficient. We are very deficient in terms of social
让人们感到非常非常担忧的原因。我在我的书中谈到了这一点，在我关于孤独的那一章里。这其实是我书中我最喜欢的一章，但造成这一现象的最大因素是科技等事物。哈佛大学的一项研究实际上发现，73%的受访者认为科技，特别是社交媒体，助长了他们的孤独状态。具体来说，它助长了我们所说的“社交零食化”，即因为社交媒体及其可及性，我们得到了这种类似一口大小的与人的互动，没有一个是真正滋养心灵的，但它们让我们勉强维持，直到我们意识到我们在营养上严重缺乏。我们在社会
connectedness and a real sense of belonging. Another factor is actually being overworked, being too busy, too tired, too high functioning to socialize. People have more to do and a greater sense of responsibility than ever. An individualistic society was something else that was named by about 58% of people in this same survey. Basically, they said people are becoming more selfish. They're becoming more self-centered. They don't want to do stuff for others. They don't want to be around others.
连结感和真正的归属感方面严重不足。另一个因素其实是过度工作，过于忙碌、过于疲惫、社会功能运转过高而无法进行社交。人们有更多的事情要做，肩上的责任感也比以往任何时候都大。个人主义社会是同一项调查中约58%的人提到的另一个因素。基本上，他们说人们变得越来越自私。他们变得越来越以自我为中心。他们不想为别人做事。他们不想和别人在一起。
And that kind of links to the final and one of the biggest factors that people cited, which was a lack of community spaces, a lack of community environments, a lack of community rituals that previous generations have had. Things like church, things like dances, like fairs, like local, that, you know, everyone went to, places and events where people could connect and the time to connect. All of these things, plus many other factors that we are most certainly going to get to, they are all contributing to the general loneliness epidemic that I think each and every one of us has felt. And it is very indicative of how disconnected we are and how isolated so many
这与人们提到的最后一个也是最大的因素之一有关，那就是缺乏社区空间，缺乏社区环境，缺乏前几代人所拥有的社区仪式。比如教堂，比如舞会，比如集市，比如当地那种你知道的，每个人都会去的、人们可以建立联系的场所和活动，以及建立联系的时间。所有这些，加上我们肯定会涉及的许多其他因素，都在助长普遍的孤独流行病，我想我们每个人都对此感同身受。这非常清楚地表明了我们是多么缺乏连结，以及有那么多
people feel. And this, like, this is a serious problem. This is a problem that very much claims lives. So how exactly does the male loneliness epidemic that people keep talking about, how does that differ from what it seems everyone else is experiencing? Well, the claim of the male loneliness epidemic is that men, specifically young men, are actually more lonely than any other group. and that the reason this is is because they are falling behind socially, which I agree with, but specifically when it comes to dating. The thing is, attention on the male loneliness epidemic to begin with was actually a really positive thing.
人感到多么孤立。而且这，这真的是一个严重的问题。这是一个切实夺走生命的问题。那么，大家一直在谈论的男性孤独流行病，究竟有何不同？它与其他人似乎正在经历的事情有何区别？好吧，关于男性孤独流行病的说法是，男性，特别是年轻男性，其实比任何其他群体都更加孤独，
It was seeking to make men more aware of the fact that they could reach out, that they would be welcomed and that they would be heard. It was trying to encourage men to become more vulnerable by seeing that not being vulnerable was a health issue. It was asking us to rethink why men were socially conditioned to seek less support, to see their mates less, to have less deep relationships, all very important questions to raise. Nowadays, though, it is transformed into something that is totally different from that conversation. And honestly, what it has transformed into from what it was initially intended to be
这背后的原因是他们在社交方面正在掉队，我对此表示赞同，但特别是在约会方面。说实话，最初对男性孤独流行病的关注其实是一件非常积极的事情。它旨在让男性更加意识到他们可以寻求帮助，他们会受到欢迎，他们的声音会被倾听。它试图通过让男性认识到不愿展露脆弱是一个健康问题，来鼓励他们变得更加脆弱。它要求我们反思，为什么社会文化会让他们减少寻求支持、减少与同伴相处、减少建立深度关系，所有这些都是非常重要且值得提出的问题。然而时至今日，它已经演变成了一种与当初的对话截然不同的东西。说实话，它从最初的初衷演变而来的结果，
means that the way the male loneliness epidemic is talked about is a huge disappointment. For straight men in particular, the claim is that because they are having less sex, because they are not dating as much, because they aren't getting married, because they're getting rejected, they are experiencing greater rates of loneliness as a result. And the discussions around why this is the case is because women, well, women won't give them a chance anymore. Women won't date them. Rejection is to blame. That is what is causing this male loneliness epidemic separate from the societal loneliness epidemic that we know we are experiencing.
意味着人们谈论男性孤独流行病的方式令人极度失望。特别是对于异性恋男性而言，其说辞是：因为他们性生活减少，因为他们约会变少，因为他们没有结婚，因为他们遭到拒绝，他们因此经历了更高程度的孤独。而关于为什么会这样的讨论则归咎于女性，嗯，女性不再给他们机会了。女性不跟他们约会了。拒绝成了罪魁祸首。这就是导致这场男性孤独流行病的元凶，它独立于我们所知道的正在经历的社会孤独流行病之外。
And here is the thing. I really don't think that this framing of male loneliness is correct. first off, and you know what, people might get frustrated at me for bringing this up, but I can only speak facts. The rates of male loneliness are no greater or bigger than the loneliness impacting every other group on earth. I'm going to break down exactly the research that proves this. And secondly, I think loneliness is actually not the issue here. It is a case whereby certain groups have been are learning that they're actually. their attitudes, their behaviours have consequences, and not wanting to own up to that.
问题就在于此。我真的认为这种对男性孤独的框架界定是不正确的。首先，你知道吗，人们可能会因为我提出这一点而感到沮丧，但我只能讲事实。男性孤独的发生率并不比地球上任何其他群体所遭受的孤独更高或更严重。我将详细剖析证明这一点的研究。其次，我认为孤独其实并不是这里的问题所在。这实际上是一个案例：某些群体正在了解到他们其实……他们的态度和行为是有后果的，而他们却不想承担责任。
So blaming their unfavorable situation on someone else, blaming it on the women who don't want to date them, who won't sleep with them, rather than understanding that amongst many other factors, they also have a personal responsibility to be the kind of person who others want to be around, who others want to have a relationship with, who others feel respected by. the male loneliness epidemic, as it is currently painted right now, I actually think is an accountability epidemic. And let me explain why I believe this in the most evidence-based, nicest way possible, because I don't think anyone deserves to be isolated. I don't think anyone deserves to feel lonely.
于是，他们将自己不利的处境归咎于他人，将之归咎于那些不想和他们约会、不肯和他们发生性关系的女性，而不是去理解，除了许多其他因素之外，他们自身也有责任成为那种别人愿意与之交往、别人愿意与之建立关系、让别人感到受到尊重的人。正如目前所描绘的那样，男性孤独流行病实际上是一个“责任推卸流行病”。让我以最讲究证据、最温和的方式来解释为什么我有这种看法，因为我认为没有人应该被孤立。我认为没有人应该感到孤独。
But I equally think that the attention the male loneliness epidemic is getting actually takes away from really addressing loneliness for men, for women, for any gender at its root cause. So firstly, let's return to that first kind of statement I made, which is that men are actually not the loneliest gender. So there is evidence that if we were to make it a competition as people who like to claim a male loneliness epidemic seem to do by pre-facing it with male, if we were to make it a competition, women are actually experiencing loneliness at a greater level than men. Here's some examples of the evidence that has been gathered around this. One such example is from Eileen Graham.
但我同样认为，男性孤独流行病所获得的关注，实际上分散了人们真正去从根本上解决男性、女性以及任何性别的孤独问题的注意力。所以首先，让我们回到我最初提出的那种说法，即男性其实并不是最孤独的性别。有证据表明，如果我们非要把它变成一场竞赛——就像那些喜欢通过加上“男性”二字来炒作男性孤独流行病的人所做的那样，如果我们非要把它变成一场竞赛，女性其实正在经历比男性更高程度的孤独。以下是一些围绕此收集到的证据示例。其中一个例子来自艾琳·格雷姆（Eileen Graham）。
She's an associate professor of social sciences at Northwestern University. She analyzed nine longitudinal studies of loneliness and found that women are actually the ones that report being lonelier than men. Now, self-reporting is actually one of the only ways that we can analyze loneliness. Loneliness is one of those weird emotions where it's actually very hard to objectively analyze. It is a completely subjective feeling. You could have two friends and feel like the most supported person in the world, or you could have a million friends and feel like the loneliest, loneliest person in the world. So it has to basically be measured through self-reporting.
她是西北大学社会科学系的副教授。她分析了九项关于孤独的纵向研究，发现实际上是女性报告自己比男性更感到孤独。现在，自我报告其实是我们分析孤独的仅有的几种方法之一。孤独是那种很诡异的情绪之一，要客观地分析它其实非常困难。这是一种完全主观的感受。你可能有两个朋友，却觉得自己是世界上获得最多支持的人；或者你可能有一百万个朋友，却觉得自己是世界上最孤独最孤独的人。所以它基本上必须通过自我报告来衡量。
And across these nine studies she looked at, there were more than 128,000 participants from over 20 countries between the ages of 13 to 103, so not a small sample size. And women consistently were the lonelier gender. Another 2024 study looked at gender differences in loneliness over a 15-year time period, a longitudinal study. Again, women were lonelier. And then a new Pew Research Center survey from January this year. looked at over 6,000 adults in the US, and it found that, once again, compared with women, men did not report being any more lonely than their counterparts. So that's three different sources, three different sources that say, actually, if we were going to make it a competition,
在她考察的那九项研究中，涉及来自20多个国家的超过12.8万名参与者，年龄在13岁到103岁之间，所以样本量并不算小。而且女性始终是更孤独的性别。另一项2024年的研究调查了15年时间跨度内孤独感的性别差异，这是一项纵向研究。同样，女性更孤独。接着，皮尤研究中心今年1月的一项新调查调查了美国6,000多名成年人，发现与女性相比，男性的报告并不比他们的同龄人表现出更高的孤独感。所以这是三个不同的来源，三个不同的来源表明，实际上，如果我们非要把它变成一场竞赛，
why is the word male in front of this? And I could honestly tell you countless others that say the same thing. So why aren't we calling it a female loneliness epidemic? You know what? I'm going to say it here. I actually don't think we need to call it male or female. The point I'm trying to make is that this shouldn't be a competition. It actually doesn't matter. Prevalence to me doesn't matter. It is a societal issue. What I bring issue to is the fact that we are trying to make it a competition and the fact that like this specific definition of loneliness for men is the only one that seems to get the attention. This kind of brings me to explaining why this specific depiction of loneliness as a male issue, as a young male issue, is perhaps not correct.
为什么这个词前面要加上“男性”？我老实说还可以告诉你无数其他持相同看法的研究。那我们为什么不把它叫做“女性孤独流行病”呢？你知道吗？我要在这里直言不讳。其实我们根本不需要把它叫作男性或女性孤独。我想表达的重点是，这不应该是一场竞赛。其实这并不重要。流行程度对我来说并不重要。这是一个社会问题。我所质疑的事实是，我们试图把它变成一场竞赛，而且事实是，似乎只有这种针对男性的孤独的特定定义才能获得关注。这在某种程度上引导我去解释，为什么这种将孤独具体描绘为一个男性问题、一个年轻男性问题的做法可能并不正确。
I want to say if you are a man and you are listening to this episode and you feel lonely, I totally feel your pain as a human being. Social isolation is super hard. This is not to invalidate your experiences. I just want to contextualize this and say again that this is not a gendered issue and it shouldn't be made to be. Let's really quickly revisit what many people claim to be the causes of the male loneliness epidemic these days. Not to sound like, you know, like a broken record, but I just want to make it super clear. The current explanation that I am addressing is that men don't have girlfriends, men don't have sex. Women don't want to date men, and therefore men don't have that same level of company that they thought they would expect.
我想说的是，如果你是一名男性，正在收听这一集并且感到孤独，作为人类我完全理解你的痛苦。社会孤立真的很难。这并不是为了否定你的经历。我只是想把这个放到语境中，并再次说明这不是一个性别化的问题，也不应该被刻意打造成性别化的问题。让我们非常简短地重温一下，现在许多人所声称的男性孤独流行病的成因。听起来可能有点像老生常谈，但我只是想把它说得超级清楚。我正在回应的当前解释是：男人没有女朋友，男人没有性生活。女性不想跟男性约会，因此男性没有他们原本期望的那种陪伴。
this is what a lot of people in the red pill male rights space is really saying is causing this issue. Now, if people were to focus on the fact that men aren't allowed to be as vulnerable as women and that's what's causing the issue, or if people wanted to focus on the fact that men lack healthy male role models, or they wanted to bring up the fact that male mental health, male eating disorders, male substance abuse issues are on the rise and that's the reason for loneliness, I would have absolutely no issue in agreeing and completely supporting that statement. I would agree with you entirely. This is a real problem. It's heartbreaking. But that is not the discussion that we're having.
这就是许多红药丸男性权利空间里真正声称导致这一问题的原因。现在，如果人们关注的是男性不被允许像女性那样展现脆弱，而这才是导致问题的原因，或者如果人们想关注的事实是男性缺乏健康的男性榜样，或者他们想提出这样一个事实：男性的心理健康、男性的饮食失调、男性的药物滥用问题正在上升，而这才是孤独的原因，我完全不介意同意并完全支持这种说法。我会完全同意你的看法。这是一个真正的问题。这令人心碎。但这并不是我们正在进行的讨论。
I would totally agree with you that society has failed many men in the same ways and for the same reasons that it has failed women and people of all genders. By making us believe we have to fit into a pigeonhole, by making men believe that they have to be strong and tough and they can't whine and they have to be brave. The patriarchy has failed men in this respect, just as it has failed women in other respects in many, many other ways as well. But that's not the focus. The focus is on what a certain group of men feel they should be entitled to, which they are not,
我完全同意你的看法，社会在许多方面、出于许多相同的原因，辜负了许多男性，正如它辜负了女性和所有性别的所有人一样。通过让我们相信我们必须挤进一个刻板的格子里，通过让男性相信他们必须坚强、硬汉、不能抱怨且必须勇敢。父权制在这方面辜负了男性，正如它在其他方面、在许多许多其他方面也辜负了女性一样。但这不是焦点。焦点在于某一部分男性觉得自己应该拥有但实际上无权拥有的东西，
which is women's bodies, women's autonomy, women's time, women's energy, women's lives. I know this is, of course, a psychology podcast, but let's do a bit of a history lesson here. for a long, long time, women depended on men for their existence, or maybe I should say, like, for their comfortable existence, beyond just surviving. Women, may I remind you, like, couldn't get a credit card or a line of credit until, like, 1984 in Australia. That means, like, my grandmother, my mother, someone, two people who are still very much alive and kicking, they weren't able to borrow money. They had their wallets and there was something in their wallet. There's something in my wallet that they didn't have in their wallet, like access to financial freedom. There was also the case that, you know, women couldn't get a job without their husband or father's permission.
那就是：女性的身体、女性的自主权、女性的时间、女性的精力、女性的生活。我知道这当然是一个心理学播客，但让我们在这里上一堂历史课。在很长很长一段时间里，女性的生存要依赖男性，或者我应该说，为了过上舒适的生活，不仅仅是维持生存。女性，请允许我提醒你们，在澳大利亚直到1984年左右都不能拥有信用卡或信用额度。这意味着，就像我的祖母、我的母亲，那些依然活得好好的、生龙活虎的人，她们以前是无法借钱的。她们有自己的钱包，而她们的钱包里有些东西是我的钱包里……哦不对，她们的钱包里缺少了某些东西，比如获得财务自由的途径。当时的情况还有，女性如果没有丈夫或父亲的许可就无法找到工作。
They were also socially outcast if they weren't married at a certain age. Every single part of their survival came down to marriage and came down to partnership with a man. Even the most disrespectful, horrible man could find someone who wanted to be with him, because he was her lifeline. He was her only ticket in. It's very simple economics around demand and supply, right? If the only way a woman can access a certain type of lifestyle is to grab a man and hope that he sticks or hope that he continues to love her, the supply is going to keep meeting that demand. Like the demand is going to mean that more men are being chosen, even if they perhaps probably didn't deserve to be.
如果在特定年龄没有结婚，她们也会被社会放逐。她们生存的每一个环节都归结为婚姻，都归结为与男性的伴侣关系。即使是最不尊重人、最糟糕的男性也能找到一个想要和他在一起的人，因为他是她的生命线。他是她唯一的入场券。这是非常简单的关于供需的经济学原理，对吧？如果一个女性获得某种生活方式的唯一途径就是抓住一个男人，希望他能坚持下去或者希望他能继续爱她，那么供给就会不断满足这种需求。需求将意味着更多的男性会被选择，即使他们可能根本不配。
This is known in psychology. It's known in sociology as the patriarchal bargain, basically referring to the strategies and compromises women needed to make for a greater level of security and autonomy, whilst still being under the control of men. Now, as we know, women have won themselves so many freedoms over the years. And so our reliance on men has diminished, and so that means that bargain is no longer in men's favour.
这在心理学和社会学中被称为“父权制契约”（the patriarchal bargain），基本上指的是女性为了获得更高水平的安全感和自主权而需要做出的策略和妥协，同时仍然处于男性的控制之下。现在，正如我们所知，女性多年来为自己赢得了如此多的自由。因此，我们对男性的依赖已经减少，这也意味着这种契约不再对男性有利。
Now, if we don't need a man out of necessity, we now get picky, as we should be, as we totally should be. If you're going to choose a live partner, you want someone who will make your life better, especially when you've already achieved a lot yourself. I look at my single friends and I'm like, they have money, they have a life they love, they're training for marathons, they own their own homes, they volunteer, they are well respected in their community, they are beautiful, they are hot, And the kind of guy who doesn't even respect you or who thinks of you as only something that could make him less lonely or is only interested in sex, he's just not going to cut it. Like the bar is too high for him. If my life as a single woman is so amazing, why would I want to be with someone who doesn't respect me? why would I want to be with someone who sees getting a girlfriend or getting a wife or getting a partner as something to tick off their to-do list and I just happen to be there?
现在，如果我们不再出于必需而需要一个男人，我们就会变得挑剔，正如我们理应做的那样，我们完全应该如此。如果你要选择一个生活伴侣，你会希望找一个能让你的生活变得更好的人，尤其是当你自己已经取得了很多成就的时候。我看着我那些单身的朋友，心想：她们有钱，她们过着自己热爱生活，她们在为马拉松进行训练，她们拥有自己的房子，她们做志愿者，她们在社区里备受尊敬，她们美丽，她们火辣。而那种甚至不尊重你、只把你当作能让他不那么孤独的工具、或者只对性感兴趣的男人，他根本不够格。标准对他来说太高了。如果我作为一个单身女性的生活如此精彩，为什么我要和一个不尊重我的人在一起呢？为什么我要和一个把找女朋友、找妻子或找伴侣当作待办事项清单上要打勾的任务、而我恰好碰上的人在一起呢？
It sounds harsh but I am sure there are certain men who feel the same way about women. I saw this comment on Reddit actually that there are certain men who will be like, you know, girls only want a guy because of money. Girls are so shallow, girls like they just reject me, you know, they, their standards are too high. And then, you know, someone will say to them like, oh, what about Brenda? You know, Brenda, she seems to really care about you and she's always there for you and she's amazing. And then the guy will be like, well, she's too fat. No, not her. Again, it's such a restricted approach to connection that actually has deep roots in patriarchy. And yet some people just don't want to
听起来很残酷，但我确信某些男性对女性也有同样的看法。我其实在Reddit上看到过这样的评论：有些男性会说，你知道的，女孩只想要有钱的男人。女孩太肤浅了，女孩……她们只是拒绝我，你知道的，她们的标准太高了。然后呢，就会有人对他们说，哦，那布伦达呢？你知道的，布伦达似乎真的很在乎你，她总是陪着你，她太棒了。然后这个男人就会说，嗯，她太胖了。不，不是她。同样地，这是一种非常局限的连接方式，它实际上在父权制中有着深厚的根源。然而有些人就是不想承认这一点，并把它变成一个非常单一的、一维的问题。女性不跟我约会，这就是我孤独的原因。我其实读过一篇非常fascinating（迷人/引人入胜）的文章，关于异性恋女性中自愿禁欲的现象正在上升。我发现的一篇《今日心理学》文章指出，六分之一的女性选择自愿禁欲，许多人表示她们从未像现在这样快乐过。我们已经到了这样一个地步：我们的性不再需要成为一种谈判筹码了。我们可以作为一个完全充实的独立女性而存在，并且有望拥有许多我们的先辈们没有的自由。随着越来越多的女性有这种感觉，
acknowledge that and want to make it a very singular one dimensional issue. Women won't date me. that's why I'm lonely. I actually read this fascinating article about voluntary celibacy being on the rise amongst straight women. A Psychology Today article I found said that one in six women are voluntarily celibate and a lot of them say they have never been happier than ever. We've gotten to a point where our sexuality doesn't have to be a bargaining tool anymore. We can just exist as a fully fulfilled solo woman and hopefully have a lot of the freedoms that, you know, our ancestors didn't have. As more and more women, you know, feel that way,
某些类型的男性将变得越来越孤立。这不是因为女性的明辨力，而是因为他们无力适应、成长并承担个人责任。好了，我们在这里稍作休息，但当我们回来时，让我们更深入地探讨这个问题以及一些潜在的解决方案。请继续收听。
certain types of men are going to become more and more isolated. Not because of a woman's discernment, but because of their inability to adapt and grow and take personal responsibility. Okay, we're going to take a short break here, but when we return, let's dive into this even deeper as well as some of the potential solutions. Stay with us.
（无语音内容/纯音乐或空转区块）
2%. That is the number of people who take the same. stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress.
2%。这就是有电梯可用时依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个光怪陆离的现代世界中，关于心理韧性、健身以及培养抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾坚信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们错了。我们在世界上恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。
Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little Kim? Well, you can find out on The Look Back at It Podcast. I'm Sam J.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端蜕变成一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是“TWO percent”（2%），在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时？我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回溯往事》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode
我是亚历克斯·恩格斯。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着去理解我们是如何挺过来的。包括最近一期邀请马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）的节目，畅谈80年代的霹雳可卡因（crack）。需要说明的是，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为霹雳可卡因。我随时准备在节目中谈论霹雳可卡因，只是想让你们都知道。我的意思是，说到这里，马克，这是我们第二期讨论霹雳可卡因了。所以我开始看出这其中有一条贯穿始终的线索。我们现在还把爱滋病（AIDS）摆上台面了。
where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah.
谢谢你把那句话说完。是的。我认为对于黑人来说，再没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。
For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month,
在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方搜索并收听《回溯往事》。欢迎来到我的新播客《艰难成长的必修课》，我是你们的主持人、你们最喜欢的治疗师科尔·盖姆斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，
I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing
我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾进行的对话。我在说。特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，在我们追求某样东西的过程中，我们太过于沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了样东西，
and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro.
而我们仍在追逐，并且不知道什么时候才算足够，因为人们都在盯着记分牌看。生活变成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得在这个世界上活着做一个好人很重要？你做一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。
Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the hard way and listen now.
绝对是的。这是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能够真正地做一个好人。加入我，我是科尔·盖姆斯，我们将在这个新播客《艰难成长的必修课》中，就疗愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用。搜索《艰难成长的必修课》并立即收听。
In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd, found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in silence, correct? I doctored the test once.
2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己陷入了亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后举行的家庭法院听证会暴露出她故事中的巨大漏洞。这就引发了一场历时多年的法庭之战来证明真相。欧文斯女士，你在沉默中两次伪造了这个特定测试，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。
It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
这需要一大批互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。
Greg, a lesbian, Michael Maranini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
格雷格，一个女同性恋，迈克尔·马拉尼尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这里是《爱之陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。
Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts,
女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻：劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts上收听《爱之陷阱》播客，
or wherever you get your podcasts. So I think in the situation I was just describing, the explanation for male loneliness being that men aren't getting laid, it's not a loneliness issue, it's an entitlement issue. I also think that it's rather sad that romantic intimacy is one of the only forms of social connection and contact that men are supposed to find fulfilling. And so they prioritize seeking out someone they desire
或在任何你获取播客的地方收听。所以我想在我刚刚描述的那种情况下，对男性孤独的解释——即男人没有性生活，这不是一个孤独问题，而是一个特权感问题。我也觉得很可悲的是，浪漫的亲密关系竟然是男性被期望觉得充实的唯一社交连接和接触形式。因此，他们优先寻找他们渴望的人并试图赢得对方的芳心，而不是专注于健康的男性友谊，而不是专注于与女性成为朋友，由好奇心而不是欲望来引导。所以当我研究这一集时，我深入研究了网上的一些红药丸男性权利群体。以下是我偶然看到的一篇Reddit帖子，我认为它完美地捕捉到了这一点。这个男人在抱怨为什么女性不喜欢他。
and who they can win over, rather than focusing on healthy male friendship, rather than focusing on being friends with women, on being led by curiosity rather than desire. So when I was researching this episode, I actually went deep-diving into some of the red pill male rights groups online. And here is a Reddit post that I came across that I think captures this perfectly. This man, he was ranting about why women don't like him.
这就是他说的真正吸引我注意力的话，我认为它触及了这个问题核心。他说，我跟她们说话的目的是为了了解她们并表现得友好。然后我会表现出浪漫的兴趣。而一旦我这么做了，我就会被拒绝。我有几个女性朋友，但她们把我当成小弟弟对待。令人恼火的是，仅仅因为她们对我不产生性吸引，女性朋友就不肯承认我是一个真正的男人。这对我来说似乎是这个问题中很大的一部分。
And this is the thing he said that really caught my attention and I think gets to the crux of this issue. He said, I talk to them with the intention of getting to know them and be friendly. And then I'll show romantic interest. And as soon as I do, I'm rejected. I have a few female friends, but they treat me like a little brother. And it's annoying that female friends won't recognize me as a man. just because they aren't sexually attracted to me. This to me seems to be a huge part of this issue.
像这样某种类型的个人，对女性友好只是为了能够对她们有所图谋，有了女性朋友却又因为她们对自己没有性吸引力而感到恼怒。这只是表明，在他的潜意识深处，他总是想着和她们约会，并且从来不把她们看作自己在友谊中的平等存在。所以我为这样的人感到难过。
A certain type of individual like this, only being friendly to women so that he can make a move on them, having female friends but then getting mad because they're not sexually attracted to him. It just shows that somewhere in the back of his mind, he's always looking to date them, and he never sees them as his equal in friendship. And so I feel bad for this kind of person.
就像你完全被排除在社会的另一个广阔侧面之外，被排除在另一群完全会在柏拉图式的层面上支持你的人之外。但因为你不想要纯粹柏拉图式的关系，你非要把它变成浪漫的关系。你就无法获得这种连结。我认为，在某种程度上，人们过分依赖女性浪漫伴侣来满足男性的所有社交和情感需求，而作为一个完整的人，你需要一个比这更广泛的社交网络。
Like you're completely cut out from a whole other side of society, a whole other group of people who are totally going to be there for you, platonically. But because you don't want something platonic, you have to make it romantic. You don't get access to that. There is this somewhat over-reliance, I think, on female romantic partners to fulfill a man's every social and emotional need when as a human being, you need a network that is more broad than that.
一个女人不能成为你唯一的解决方案。而且，你也应该能够向你的伴侣提供这种支持。听着，她们不仅仅是让你感觉不那么孤独的工具。如果你只是想要一个女朋友来感觉不那么孤独，或者为了得到无条件的爱，去养一只狗吧。去养一只狗。相信我，收容所里到处都是。你在那里会找到你想要的东西。总之，女性要
A woman cannot be your only solution. But also, you should be able to provide that support back to your partner. Like, they aren't just something to have so that you feel less lonely. If you only want a girlfriend to feel less lonely or for unconditional love, get a dog. Get a dog. Trust me, the pounds are full. You will find what you are looking for there. Like, women are.
比仅仅是你想要约会的对象要复杂得多。事情就是这样。我有非常棒的男性朋友，我真心爱戴和钦佩他们。我此刻脑海中浮现出他们的身影，我只想说，哇，你们真是男子气概的绝佳榜样，因为他们（出于种种原因），因为他们视女性为平等的人，有时甚至视女性为他们的上级，他们将女性视为他们钦佩、想要效仿且不只是想与之发生性关系的独立个体。而且你猜怎么着？抛开这些不谈，当他们确实去追求某人时，他们能约到会。他们有真正让他们感到充实的伴侣。他们订婚了。他们结婚了。他们并不孤独，因为他们拥有一种使建立连接成为可能的态度，因为他们是善良的人。再说一次，
more complex than just something that you want to date. This is the thing. I have such amazing male friends who I genuinely love and admire. And I'm thinking about them in my mind right now and I'm just like, wow, you guys are such great examples of masculinity because they, for many reasons, but because they see women as their equals, sometimes even as their superiors, they see women as people they admire that they want to be like and that they don't just want to sleep with. And guess what? Separate to that, when they do pursue someone, they get dates. They have partners who genuinely fulfill them. They're engaged. They're married. They're not lonely because they have an attitude that makes connecting with them possible because they are nice people. And again,
比仅仅是一个你想约会的人要复杂得多。这就是问题所在。我有一些非常棒的男性朋友，我是真的非常爱他们、钦佩他们。我脑海里现在正想着他们，我心里就在想，哇，你们真是男子气概的绝佳榜样，因为他们出于很多原因，把女性视为平等的存在，有时甚至视为比自己更优秀的人，他们把女性视为他们钦佩、想要效仿的对象，而不仅仅是想和她们发生性关系。你猜怎么着？抛开这些不谈，当他们确实去追求某人时，他们能约到人。他们的伴侣能真正地满足他们。他们订婚了。他们结婚了。他们并不孤独，因为他们有一种态度，使得与他们建立联系成为可能，因为他们是好人。而且再说一次，
it's not just like that a man is, he's lonely because he's awful. There are a lot of men who are lonely and the fact they can't find love is a part of that the same way that there are a lot of women or non-binary people who are lonely because they really want a life partner but they aren't then blaming the person or people not picking them for their entire circumstances and doing nothing to change it humans have a natural desire for intimacy i'm not saying that you need to be okay with never finding love and to get over it and otherwise you deserve to be lonely no it's it's in your DNA to want someone to love and to love you. It's in our nature to have someone and have a group of people who care about us. But you're also not entitled to it from an individual just because historically,
这不仅仅是因为一个男人本身就是这样，他感到孤独是因为他真的很糟糕。有很多男人感到孤独，他们找不到真爱也是其中一部分原因，就像有很多女性或非二元性别者感到孤独一样，因为他们真的想要一个生活伴侣，但他们并没有因此去责怪那些没有选择他们的人并把这归咎于他们的整个人生现状，却什么都不做去改变它。人类对亲密关系有着天然的渴望，我并不是说你需要对永远找不到真爱这件事泰然处之并彻底放下，否则你就活该孤独，不是的，想要有人去爱以及被人爱是刻在你的DNA里的。拥有某个人以及一个关心我们的群体是我们的天性。但你也不能仅仅因为从历史上看，
it was easier to come by for someone in your circumstances. And you can't then turn around and make it sound like not getting a date is an epidemic and everyone's problem. Because let's be real, there are a ton of lonely, single women out there who have never dated someone, who have been rejected countless times. And I can promise you they are not on 4chan boards spewing violence and hate and saying that all men are the problem. So what have the consequences of the male loneliness epidemic been? And let me say again, not the general loneliness epidemic that includes men, but this specifically marketed loneliness epidemic of men not getting dates. What is the harm of this been. I think a big consequence of the publicity this is getting is that certain men are being pushed
对于你这种处境的人来说，寻找伴侣曾经更容易，就理所当然地认为某个个体也必须满足你。然后你不能反过来说，找不到约会对象是一种流行病，是所有人的问题。因为说实话，有成千上万孤独的单身女性，她们从未约会过，被拒绝了无数次。我可以向你保证，她们没有在4chan论坛上散播暴力和仇恨，并说所有的男人都是问题的根源。那么，男性孤独流行病的后果是什么呢？请容我再次强调，这并不是指包含男性的普遍孤独流行病，而是指这种被专门营销的、针对男性找不到约会对象的孤独流行病。这到底带来了什么危害。我认为这种宣传带来的一个巨大后果是，某些男人被推得
deeper and deeper into the manosphere, whereby the loudest voices and people, the people with the biggest platforms are fellow men who are jacked and they're really handsome, and they claim to be rich. And they're telling you that you're not the problem. They're paying. They're paying. painting women as villains either explicitly or implicitly, and that is not the case. I genuinely feel like a deep level of concern and worry for young men who end up in these spaces, because I know what's waiting for them is more loneliness. It becomes harder and harder to find someone, harder to connect with others meaningfully, harder to realize that this person does not have your best interests at heart by spewing this narrative to you
越来越深入所谓的“男权世界”（manosphere），在那里，声音最大的人、拥有最大平台的那些人，都是一些身材健硕、非常帅气并且自称很富有的同行男性。他们告诉你，你没有问题。他们正在。他们正在。把女性明确或隐含地描绘成反派，而事实并非如此。对于那些最终落入这些空间的年轻男性，我内心深处其实充满了关切和担忧，因为我知道等待他们的是更多的孤独。想要找到某个人变得越来越难，与他人进行有意义的连接变得越来越难，认清向你灌输这种叙事的人其实根本没有为你着想，也变得越来越难，
the further you're indoctrinated. It also will ironically, logically, further kill your chances of finding love because guess what? Most women don't want to be with someone who inherently blames her for his deeper issues. According to the United Nations convoy on women, the manosphere, as we call it, is actually making misogyny more mainstream. it's making it a more widely held belief system. And here's the kicker. Individuals who feel a sense of social isolation are more likely to fall victim to it. If you want an even scarier statistic,
你越陷越深。而且讽刺的是，从逻辑上讲，这会进一步断送你找到真爱的机会，因为你猜怎么着？大多数女性都不想和一个把自己的深层问题完全归咎于她的人在一起。根据联合国妇女问题特使的说法，我们所说的“男权世界”实际上正在使厌女症变得更加主流。它正在使其成为一种更广泛持有的信仰体系。最厉害的是：那些感到社会孤立感的人更容易成为受害者。如果你想要一个更可怕的数据，
that doesn't scare you enough about two-thirds of young men regularly engage or exposed to these kinds of influences online. An engagement with these kinds of individuals is linked to greater levels of digital abuse towards women. Again, these male influencers are great at their jobs. Let's just call it as it is.
如果这还不够让你感到害怕的话，大约三分之二的年轻男性经常在网上接触或受到这类影响。而与这类群体的接触，会导致针对女性的数字虐待程度更高。再说一次，这些男性网红很擅长他们的工作。我们就实话实说吧。
They are great at influencing. And they are also great at providing an echo chamber without actually helping these men. And without actually improving their chances of being able to positively engage with these people. I would be more on board with these kind of male influences if they actually talked about mental health. if they actually said, hey, you're lonely? Let's create like a volunteer group. If they actually were like, let's actually encourage you to set a goal for yourself and didn't always bring it back to so that you can be more like a man and you can get women. It's just an authentic. And this is harmful for everyone. It's harmful for men who are looking for
他们非常擅长发挥影响力。而且他们也非常擅长提供一个回音室，却没有真正帮助这些男人。也没有真正提高他们与这些人进行积极交往的能力。如果这些男性网红真的谈论心理健康，我会更支持他们。如果他们真的说，嘿，你感到孤独吗？让我们成立一个像志愿者那样的组织。如果他们真的说，让我们鼓励你为自己设定一个目标，而不是总是把它扯回“这样你就能更像个男人、就能搞定女人”。这太不真实了。这对所有人都是有害的。这对那些正在寻找
a lifeline and who could really benefit from some real, like some real mental health support and positive like male role models, they just end up getting more isolated and lonely. It's also harmful for women. It's harmful for women who end up being victims of this women of the villain idea, this women of the villain rhetoric that further allows people to dehumanize them. And I can say this right now. This type of behavior, this pipeline from lonely man into digital abuse against women. It's happened to me. Like, I've seen this firsthand. I had a video go viral last year, a really innocent video about how I want to date a man who is self-aware. The top three comments on that video were three separate men calling me fat, calling me ugly,
救命稻草、并且本可以真正从中受益的男性来说是有害的，比如一些真正的心理健康支持和积极的男性榜样，他们最终却变得更加孤立和孤独。这对女性也是有害的。这对那些最终成为“女性是恶人”这一观念受害者的女性是有害的，“女性是恶人”这种修辞进一步助长了人们对女性的非人化。我现在就可以这么说。这种行为，从孤独男性到针对女性的数字虐待的这条管道。它发生在我身上。就像，我亲眼目睹过这一切。我去年发了一个视频，点击量很高，那是一个非常无辜的视频，讲的是我想和一个有自我意识的男人约会。那个视频置顶的三条评论是三个不同的男人说我很胖、说我很丑、
calling me stupid, calling me a slut, saying they would never date me. All because I said, I would like a man who has been to therapy. Bear in mind, I'm going to brag. I'm going to brag for a bit. I have a fantastic boyfriend. He's six for five. He's a lawyer. He loves his mother.
说我很愚蠢，叫我荡妇，说他们永远不会跟我约会。仅仅因为我说，我希望找一个去过心理治疗的男人。记住，我要吹嘘一下。我要自吹自擂一会儿。我有一个极好的男朋友。他身高六英尺五英寸（约1.96米）。他是一名律师。他很爱他的母亲。
He has wonderful male friends who I actually talk to for this episode. And yet the biggest insult they could think of when they didn't agree with me was that they wouldn't date me and that I was ugly according to them. And then they wonder why they're lonely. and they wonder why women don't want to date them, as if it is some big mystery. And yet I still have sympathy for them because I know, like, I saw these comments and I was like, oh, God, I want to argue with you. I want to get mad at you. And I just look at them, I'm like, you are just the victim of something so much bigger than you that you are not even aware of,
他有着很棒的男性朋友，我在制作这一集节目时还跟他们聊过。然而，当他们不同意我的观点时，他们能想到的最大侮辱竟然是他们不会跟我约会，而且按照他们的标准我很丑。然后他们还奇怪自己为什么会孤独。他们奇怪为什么女性不想和他们约会，好像这是一个多大的谜团一样。然而我对他们仍然心存同情，因为我知道，就像，我看到这些评论时，我就想，天哪，我想跟你吵架。我想生你的气。但我只是看着他们，心里想：你不过是某个比你大得多、而你自己甚至都没有意识到的东西的受害者，
and I'm so sorry. So let's talk a bit further about the consequences of this, not for men, but for women. Let's go further into the trenches of how women are bearing the brunt of this. The biggest thing, one of the biggest consequences of this is that actually women are facing an increased sense of responsibility for men's mental health and for men's needs. Yet again, yet again, it becomes a woman's problem. This happens in relationships. It happens in friendships. It happens in sibling relationships. It happens with housemates. It happens with co-workers.
我真的感到很遗憾。所以让我们进一步谈谈这个现象的后果，不是对男性的后果，而是对女性的后果。让我们更深入地探讨女性是如何承受这一切沉重代价的。最主要的事情，也是最大的后果之一，实际上是女性正在承担起对男性心理健康和男性需求的更多责任。又一次，又一次，这成了女性的问题。这种情况发生在恋爱关系中。发生在友情中。发生在兄弟姐妹关系中。发生在室友之间。发生在同事之间。
To quote the writer Roe McDermott, this gap in emotional caregiving in relationships between men and women leaves men even more unhappy because they don't develop individual emotional regulation skills, and it yet again leaves women with more work, giving more emotional care than they receive, which then in turn breathes resentments and makes relationships fail. Feminist scholars have often labelled this emotional labor, but the researcher Ellie Anderson,
借用作家罗·麦克德莫特（Roe McDermott）的话说：“男女关系中这种情感照顾的缺失，让男性变得更加不快乐，因为他们没有发展出个体的情绪调节能力，而这又一次给女性留下了更多的工作，她们付出的情感关怀多于她们所收到的，这反过来又滋生了怨恨并导致关系破裂。”女权主义学者经常将此称为“情感劳动”（emotional labor），但研究员埃莉·安德森（Ellie Anderson）
and she's recently identified a more nuanced definition for this called hermeneutic labor. Hermeneutic labor is the demanding often unrecognized task that women face of interpreting, articulating, deciphering the feelings and intentions of others and navigating the resulting interpersonal tensions. Let me get this completely straight. Men and women, neither of them are naturally better at this, Women have just been conditioned to be better at it. And they have been conditioned to be better at it
最近为这种现象确定了一个更细致的定义，叫做“诠释劳动”（hermeneutic labor）。诠释劳动是女性所面临的一项要求极高且常常不被认可的任务，即去解读、表达、揣摩他人的感受和意图，并应对由此产生的人际紧张关系。让我把这一点彻底澄清。无论男女，天生都没有谁在这方面更擅长，女性只是被后天塑造得更擅长此道。而且她们之所以被塑造得更擅长此道，
because they have often been, again, painted as the caretakers of others around them, including men. And that mental load takes its toll. And again, it hurts both people. It hurts all genders. It hurts women because suddenly they're responsible for another human's emotions, another adult's emotions, and they're now bearing the bruntlets.
是因为她们经常又一次被描绘成周围其他人（包括男性）的照顾者。而这种精神负担带来了沉重的代价。而且再次说明，这伤害了双方。这伤害了所有性别。它伤害了女性，因为突然之间她们要对另一个人类的、另一个成年人的情绪负责，而她们现在却要承担首当其冲的冲击。
of perhaps like of like an entire gender's loneliness which they don't deserve to and it hurts men because they should be better equipped with the emotional skills that they need to decipher their own emotions but because again we have like taught women that that's their job we've also taught men that they don't need to learn that skill which is ridiculous everyone needs to learn that skill let's also talk about violence against women which is a bit of a trigger warning that obviously this discussion might be a little bit heavy for some people, but we just can't not talk about it, obviously. I'm honest, I should have talked about it earlier, but violence against women is my biggest point to make in this whole thing. I will say again, I ask some of my
这可能就像是一个整个性别的孤独感，而她们根本不应该承受这些；这也伤害了男性，因为他们本该具备应对自己情绪所需的情感技巧，但又一次，因为我们教导女性那是她们的工作，我们也同时教导男性他们不需要学习这种技能，这太荒谬了。每个人都需要学习这种技能。让我们也来谈谈针对女性的暴力问题，这可能会引发一些创伤应激（trigger warning），显然这个讨论对某些人来说可能有点沉重，但我们显然不能不谈论它。老实说，我本该早点谈论这个的，但针对女性的暴力是我在整件事中最想强调的核心观点。我再说一次，我曾向我的一些
male friends, their thoughts on the male loneliness epidemic, because I just wanted to know their perspectives as men. You know, I'm a woman. I probably could never understand. I can never understand what they're experiencing. But I have to quote one of my friends, shout out to Alex, who message me this when I asked. I was like, what do you think about the male loneliness epidemic? And he said, let's be clear. As much as loneliness is an issue for men, it will never compare to the epidemic of violence against women. Violence against women is on the rise. And it is very clearly killing women. It is a clear aid to. to be. Violence against women kills women. And it's not a coincidence that as it's increased,
男性朋友询问他们对“男性孤独流行病”的看法，因为我只是想了解他们作为男性的视角。你知道的，我是一个女人。我可能永远无法理解。我永远无法理解他们正在经历什么。但我必须引用我的一位朋友的话，向亚历克斯（Alex）致敬，当我问他时，他给我发了这条信息。我当时问：你对男性孤独流行病怎么看？他说：我们要搞清楚。尽管孤独对男性来说是一个问题，但它永远无法与针对女性的暴力流行病相提并论。针对女性的暴力正在上升。而且它非常明显地在夺去女性的生命。这是一个明显的助长……成为。针对女性的暴力会夺走女性的生命。这绝非巧合，随着这种暴力现象的增加，
so is the prevalence of these manosphere circles, so is the prevalence of terms like male loneliness epidemic. Why is it that the male loneliness epidemic seemingly always seems to be trending, but the names of women who lost their lives to domestic violence, to intimate partner violence, to random male violence, are not? And here's And here's the thing. I really think that the more men are pushed into the space of thinking that the reason they're lonely is because women don't respect them or won't date them, the more we will see the numbers go up. The more violence will increase. It's very basic social psychology, right? When men experience for loneliness, rejection, social disconnection, there's a strong temptation, encouraged by the Manosphere circles, to blame women as the cause of their suffering. This has a word. It's called scapegoating. rather than confronting actual structural issues like gendered expectations, economic shifts, limited male socialization,
这些男权世界圈子的盛行也在增加，像“男性孤独流行病”这样的术语的盛行也是如此。为什么“男性孤独流行病”似乎总是在登上热搜，而那些因家庭暴力、亲密伴侣暴力、随机男性暴力而失去生命的女性的名字却从来不上热搜？事情是这样的。我真的认为，男人们越是被推入这样一种空间——让他们认为自己孤独的原因是女性不尊重他们或不愿与他们约会，我们就会看到相关数字上升得越多。暴力就会越多。这是非常基础的社会心理学，对吧？当男性经历孤独、拒绝、社会断连时，在男权世界圈子的煽动下，他们会产生一种强烈的诱惑，把女性当作他们痛苦的根源来指责。这有一个专门的词，叫做“替罪羊化”（scapegoating）。与其去面对实际的结构性问题，比如性别期待、经济变革、有限的男性社交，
the responsibility is displaced onto women. The psychological payoff is that it gives them a clear enemy to hold accountable, even if the actual causes are much broader and more complex. Scapegoating, it doesn't only reduce feelings of helplessness, it also fuels hostility towards the targeted group, which in this case translates into violence. Social identity theory will also tell you and tell us that people derive self-worth from belonging to a group. So when men perceive that they are excluded by women from dating or from socializing, they may strengthen identification with an in-group of other disaffected men.
他们却把责任转嫁到了女性身上。这样做的心理回报是，它为他们提供了一个清晰的、需要对其负责的敌人，即使真正的原因要广泛得多、复杂得多。替罪羊化不仅能减少无助感，还会加剧对目标群体的敌意，在这种情况下，这就转化成了暴力。社会认同通过理论也会告诉你、告诉我们，人们的自我价值感来自于对一个群体的归属。因此，当男性认为自己被女性排除在约会或社交之外时，他们可能会加强对由其他失意男性组成的内部群体的认同。
Women then become the outgroup against which all their grievances are projected. Once that division is drawn, it's very easy for stereotypes to be amplified. Women are shallow. Women are manipulative. Women are rejecting. Women only want me for my money. Whilst the men in the in-group are encouraged to see themselves as misunderstood victims. That us versus them dynamic?
于是，女性就成了外部群体，他们所有的不满都投射在这个群体身上。一旦划清了这种界限，刻板印象就很容易被放大。女人都是肤浅的。女人都是工于心计的。女人都是会拒绝人的。女人跟我在一起只是为了我的钱。而内部群体的男性则被鼓励把自己视为被误解的受害者。这种“我们对他们”的动态关系？
That is just like the most fertile ground there is for hostility. Again, no one benefits from this. This is why let's scrap male loneliness epidemic. Let's scrap female loneliness epidemic. Let's talk about this not as a gendered issue, but through a lens where this is a collective problem that we need to address. We're going to take a short break here. But when we return, I want to talk about that specifically.
这简直就是滋生敌意的最肥沃的土壤。再说一次，没有人能从中受益。这就是为什么我们要废除“男性孤独流行病”这个说法。我们要废除“女性孤独流行病”这个说法。让我们不要把这当作一个性别问题来讨论，而是要透过这样一个镜头：这是一个我们需要共同解决的集体问题。我们在这里稍作休息。但当我们回来时，我想专门谈谈这一点。
What are some of the solutions? 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong.
有哪些解决方案呢？2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在 我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、体能和抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，带大家看透那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾经坚信种子油本质上会引发炎症。我们弄错了。
Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you're you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J.
我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的 人。收听《2%》。也就是“TWO percent”，可在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上双击（拍打）小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人时？我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but yeah, yeah, literally. But just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line.
我是亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。在每一集中，我们都会精选话题，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何在其中幸存下来的。包括最近一集请来了马马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Marc Lamont Hill），滔滔不绝地聊了聊80年代的快克毒品。坦白说，84年对我意义重大，不仅仅是因为快克。我很乐意在某天聊聊快克，但对，对，确实如此。不过只是想让你们大家知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了。所以我开始看出这里面有一条贯穿始终的主线。
We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我们现在还把“艾滋病”这个话题摆在了桌面上。谢谢你帮我把这句话说完。是的。我认为对黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年之一。请在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你收听播客的地方收听《Look Back at It》。
Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and comments. conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing.
欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是主持人、也是你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines）。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将结合我在心理健康领域十多年的丰富经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾进行的对话。我说的是。特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们执着于追求某样东西时，我们会在追逐的过程中深陷其中，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。
And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Or are you a good person because you're afraid?
而我们却还在继续追逐。并且我们不知道什么时候才算“够了”。因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了一场关于胜利与失败的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross）。因为你觉得在这个世上做一个好人很重要？还是你做个好人只是因为你害怕？
Because that's two different intentions. bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keer Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free, our Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives
因为这是两种不同的动机。兄弟。绝对是。而且这是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正地、纯粹地做一个好人。加入我和基尔·盖恩斯的行列，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，就疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和人生目标展开真实的对话。打开免费的IHeart Radio应用。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Echard）发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的风口浪尖。随后的家庭法庭听证会暴露了他故事中明显的自相矛盾之处。这开启了一场长达数年的、旨在证明真相的法庭之战。你篡改过这个特定的测试两次，对吧？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一支网络侦探大队
to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Lusby and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges.
来破解这个案件。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税都被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会揭开一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·卢斯比（Greg Lusby）和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我的天啊，我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。
This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome back. Let's talk about some nuanced, healthy. proactive ways to counteract loneliness so that we can really get to the root cause of this issue before it is allowed to be further distorted and divided and twisted. Number one, if we're going to approach the loneliness epidemic, we need to recognize,
在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这件事不会结束。请在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你收听播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。欢迎回来。让我们来谈谈一些细腻、健康、积极的方法来对抗孤独，这样我们就能真正找到这个问题的根源，而不是任由它被进一步歪曲、分化和扭曲。第一点，如果我们想要应对孤独流行病，我们需要认识到，
it's going to sound counterintuitive, but we need to recognize that being lonely is actually something that we are all going to go through. It is universal. It is difficult, but it is not someone else's fault or responsibility. It is something that every single person is going to experience. at some stage. Again, I was talking to my boyfriend about this, about the male loneliness epidemic, and he asked me, do you think the reason people are so worried about this is because they see loneliness as like a curse rather than just as a human experience? And I was like, whoa, wow, I totally have to agree with you there. I think we have this tendency to villainize loneliness. And obviously, prolonged exposure to loneliness is super harmful, but it is also a
这听起来可能有点反直觉，但我们需要认识到，感到孤独其实是我们所有人都会经历的事情。它是普遍存在的。这很艰难，但这并不是别人的错或责任。这是每一个人都会在某个阶段经历的事情。再次说明，我和男友谈过这件事，关于男性孤独流行病，他问我，你觉得人们之所以对此如此担忧，是因为他们把孤独看作是一种诅咒，而不是仅仅看作一种人类的体验吗？当时我就想：哇，天哪，我完全同意你的看法。我认为我们有一种将孤独妖魔化的倾向。显然，长期暴露在孤独中是非常有害的，但它也是一个
sign that something is missing. To me, loneliness is like hunger. It is like thirst. It is like tiredness. It is a sign that you have a very basic social need or a very basic human need that is not being met. And if you were thirsty, if you were hungry, if you were tired, you're not just going to sit there and be like, well, I'm really, really hungry and I'm really, really tired. And not then try and sleep, not then try and find something to eat, not then try and find something to drink. Obviously, it's a lot more complex than that, and I'll talk about some of the strategies we can use to fulfill that loneliness whole, but we need to treat it as a sign that something is missing, and that's not a singular thing that's missing. It's not a boyfriend,
信号，表明有什么东西缺失了。对我来说，孤独就像饥饿。就像口渴。就像疲惫。它是一个信号，表明你有一个非常基础的社会需求或非常基础的人类需求没有得到满足。如果你口渴了，如果你饿了，如果你累了，你不会只是坐在那里说，嗯，我真的真的很饿，我真的真的很累。然后不去尝试睡觉，不去尝试找点东西吃，不去尝试找点东西喝。显然，这要复杂得多，我稍后会谈到一些我们可以用来填补孤独空虚的策略，但我们需要把它当作一个信号，表明有什么东西缺失了，而且缺失的并不是单一的东西。不是一个男朋友，
it's not a girlfriend, it is a larger inadequacy or deficiency in terms of support. That is really what's happening here, and that brings me to the second thing we need to address, which is the real structural causes of loneliness beyond a micro-individual level. Blaming one person, even blaming a group of people, like it's never going to get you anywhere. But if we want something or someone to blame, as we often do, let's turn our direction to a common enemy, how society has been set up by people long, long gone in a terrible way for which we are now facing the consequences. Mainly, the common enemy is the patriarchy, which hurts both men and women. It's division between genders. It's stigma about mental health. It's stigma around vulnerability. It's society's obsession with productivity
也不是一个女朋友，而是在支持方面更广泛的不足或缺陷。这才是真正发生的事情，这就引出了我们需要解决的第二件事，即超越微观个人层面的孤独的真正结构性原因。责备一个人，甚至责备一群人，永远不会带你走向任何地方。但如果我们想要找个人或某个东西来责备（就像我们经常做的那样），让我们把目光转向一个共同的敌人：社会是如何被很久很久以前的人们以一种糟糕的方式建立起来的，而我们现在正在承担其后果。主要地，这个共同的敌人就是父权制，它同时伤害了男性和女性。它是性别之间的分歧。它是关于心理健康的污名。它是围绕脆弱感的污名。它是社会对生产力的迷恋，
so that none of us have time or energy to connect with others anymore. It's the loss of community through the commercialization of previously accessible spaces. It's the fact that we don't have livable or affordable cities where people can actually see each other and hang out and meet other people incidentally. Anything else is, it's quite frankly, it's a red herring. It's distracting us from the main issue. It's distracting us from the serious factors that are at play. Again, I went looking into some of those bread pill, manosphere, group chats, and Reddit pages. And you know what really disappointed me was how easily distracted they are from what is really causing their loneliness or because a woman rejected them, or all because a
以至于我们所有人都没有时间或精力再去与他人建立联系。它是通过对原本无障碍的空间进行商业化而导致的社群的丧失。是我们没有宜居或负担得起的城市，让人们能够真正地看到彼此、闲逛并偶然结识其他人。除此之外的其他任何东西，坦白说，都是干扰视线的红鲱鱼（误导项）。它分散了我们对主要问题的注意力。它分散了我们对那些正在发挥作用的严肃因素的注意力。再次说明，我去浏览了一些红药丸（red pill）、男权世界的群聊和Reddit页面。你知道真正让我失望的是什么吗？他们是多么轻易地就被转移了视线，忽视了导致他们孤独的真正原因，或者仅仅因为一个女性拒绝了他们，或者因为一个
woman was involved. They will get so close to the truth and then they will fall short. This is an exact comment on a post titled, The Men's Loneliness Epidemic is Real and Why We Shouldn't Say Otherwise, in a Reddit group called Men's Rights. Quote, I saw a news article about male loneliness epidemic, and all it talked about was how it affected women. I dislocated my knee at work,
女性卷入其中。他们明明已经无限接近真相，却又功亏一篑。这是Reddit上一个名为“男性权利”（Men's Rights）的群组中，一篇题为《男性的孤独流行病是真实的，为什么我们不应该反驳》的帖子下的一条确切评论。引述如下：“我看到一篇关于男性孤独流行病的新闻报道，里面通篇都在讨论它如何影响女性。我在工作中扭伤了膝盖，
and no one messaged me or contacted me to see if I was doing okay or anything. But when one of the women went on leave for a sore back, they sent her get well card. and some cash. End quote. Do you see what I'm talking about? This to me is a prime example of this poor guy being mad at the woman who got the card and not at the system that meant that you didn't feel you could reach out or the system that made it seem that because you were a man, you could be strong and they didn't have to help you. What if instead of focusing on what women could or could not do for men. Why does a male versus female problem, we focused on how this is a resource issue,
没有人给我发信息或联系我，看我是否还好或者别的什么。但是当其中一个女性因为背痛请假时，他们给她寄了一张慰问卡和一些现金。”引述结束。你们看到我在说什么了吗？在我看来，这堪称一个典型的例子：这个可怜的家伙在生那个收到贺卡的女性的气，而不是去生那个体制的气——正是这个体制让你觉得你无法向他人求助，或者是这个体制让你觉得因为你是个男人，你就必须坚强，所以他们不需要帮助你。如果不是去关注女性能或不能为男性做些什么，为什么这是一个“男对女”的问题，而是我们把焦点放在这是一个资源问题、
a time issue, a mental health issue, a system issue. If someone brings up the male loneliness epidemic to you, I think it's an invitation to instead steer them towards the bigger picture by saying, you know, yeah, it's so awful that men are made to feel so limited in their emotional capabilities that being in a relationship is their only cured of loneliness. That really does suck. Or say like, yes, it is so hard that mental health and physical health struggles are so stigmatized that people feel isolated. Or bring up the statistics that we talked about before. Men and women are equally lonely because we are all lacking from opportunities to meaningfully connect. That's something we really need to fix as a collective, don't we?
时间问题、心理健康问题、体制问题上，那会怎样呢？如果有人向你提起男性孤独流行病，我认为这是一个契机，你可以借此引导他们看到更宏观的画面，你可以说：“你知道的，是的，男人们被迫在情感能力上受到如此大的限制，以至于身处一段恋爱关系成了他们唯一的孤独解药，这真的很糟糕。”或者说：“是的，心理健康和身体健康问题被如此严重地污名化，以至于人们感到孤立，这太难了。”或者提起我们之前讨论过的数据：男女在孤独感上是不相上下的，因为我们都缺乏有意义连接的机会。这是我们需要作为集体真正去修复的问题，对吧？
And whatever gender you are, if you see an issue with loneliness in your life or in your community, become the person that fixes that. Be the instigator. Make a run club. Invite people over for dinner at your house. Become the host. Join a book club or make a book club. Get a foster dog and walk it in the park.
无论你是什么性别，如果你在自己的生活或社群中看到了孤独的问题，那就成为那个去解决问题的人。成为发起人。组建一个跑步俱乐部。邀请大家来你家里吃晚饭。成为聚会的主办者。加入一个读书俱乐部，或者自己创建一个读书俱乐部。领养一只寄养犬并在公园里遛它。
The amount of people you will meet and talk to is mind blowing. Volunteer, even if it's through work. Like there are so many other options here. And if you have other suggestions of things that you've done, please like drop them below. So the third thing, number three, third thing, we need to do it is we need to not engage with Manosphere influences that make men feel more isolated and instead promote healthy male role models. If you see someone spouting just like plain nonsense, block them. Press uninterested.
你会遇到并交谈的人数会多得超乎你的想象。去做志愿者，哪怕是通过工作去做。这里有太多的其他选择了。如果你对做过的事情有其他建议，请在下方留言。所以第三件事，第三点，第三个我们需要做的事是：我们不应该去理会那些让男性感到更加孤立的男权世界网红，而是应该去宣传健康的男性榜样。如果你看到有人在胡说八道，直接拉黑他们。点击“不感兴趣”。
Do not comment. Do not like. Do not argue. Do not engage. Stop giving these people oxygen. and instead make it a point to follow, engage, comment, like, reshare content from healthy male role models. Here are some examples of people who I think are just absolutely excellent. The first one is Ned Brockman. He was an electrician who ran across Australia in a couple of years ago and he raised $2.6 million for homelessness. And he continues to share super, super inspiring stuff. Super healthy male role model. I'd be so happy if my sons turned out like him.
不要评论。不要点赞。不要争论。不要互动。不要再给这些人提供生存空间，相反，我们要明确地去关注、互动、评论、点赞和转发来自健康男性榜样的内容。以下是我认为绝对优秀的人选的一些例子。第一个是内德·布罗克曼（Ned Brockman）。他是一名电工，几年前跑遍了整个澳大利亚，为无家可归者筹集了260万美元。他一直在分享超级超级鼓舞人心的内容。超级健康的男性榜样。如果我的儿子们能像他一样，我会非常高兴。
Hank Green, another great example. He was just battling cancer and he continued to share his journey throughout that. And he continues to like inform people about science, about news. He's great. Dak Shepard and his podcast Armchair expert, he also overcame a substance abuse problem. He talks about that very openly. Dr. J. Barnett, incredible man, I love his stuff. Tom Daly as well, love him as well.
汉克·格林（Hank Green），另一个极好的例子。他一直在与癌症作斗争，并在整个过程中继续分享他的抗癌历程。他一直在向人们普及科学和新闻知识。他太棒了。达克·谢泼德（Dak Shepard）和他的播客《Armchair Expert》，他也曾战胜物质滥用问题。他非常公开地谈论这一点。J·巴尼特博士（Dr. J. Barnett），一个不可思议的男人，我非常喜欢他的内容。汤姆·戴利（Tom Daly）也是，我也非常喜欢他。
Like, I can keep going. I can list all these amazing men who I think are great examples of what it means to be a man who asked for help, who is connected, who talks about struggle, who also does really cool stuff. You know, the show that I think every man should be required to watch at school, it's Ted Lassau. Like, that show is one of the most amazing things ever made. And it talks about male loneliness. It talks about men's mental health. and masculinity and divorce and breakups in like the most wonderful, positive way that is actually productive. We need more of that.
诸如此类，我可以一直列举下去。我可以列出所有这些了不起的男人，我认为他们是真正优秀典范——他们懂得如何成为一个敢于寻求帮助、与他人紧密相连、敢于谈论挣扎、同时也做着非常酷的事情的男人。你知道的，我认为每个男人在学校里都应该被要求看的一部剧，就是《足球教练》（Ted Lassau）。这部剧简直是有史以来最了不起的作品之一。它探讨了男性的孤独。它探讨了男性的心理健康、男子气概、离婚以及分手，并且以一种最美妙、最积极、真正具有建设性的方式。我们需要更多这样的作品。
Number four, we need to call out the men in our lives. Now, this is specifically for other men. Silence is complicity. And one of the most powerful ways to shift culture is not through big articles, outrage, Instagram posts, even podcasts like this one. We know it's through everyday accountability. When men hear their friends, brothers, colleagues, strangers make sexist jokes, belittle women, dismiss conversations about violence, or continue to spur toxic myths about masculinity, those moments are really critical. Too often they slide unchallenged because it's uncomfortable.
第四点，我们需要公开指出我们生活中男性的问题。现在，这一点是专门针对其他男性的。沉默就是同谋。而改变文化最强大的方式之一，不是通过长篇大论的文章、愤怒的声讨、Instagram帖子，甚至不是通过像这样的播客。我们都知道，这是通过日常的问责来实现的。当男性听到他们的朋友、兄弟、同事、陌生人开性别歧视的玩笑、贬低女性、对暴力对话不屑一顾，或者继续散播关于男子气概的有毒神话时，那些时刻真的至关重要。很多时候，这些言论没有受到任何挑战就滑过去了，因为这让人感到不舒服。
It's uncomfortable. I've had times where I haven't spoken about things I really should have, but that only silently reinforces a belief system that is hurting your fellow man. when another man steps in, whether it's like a simple, like that's not funny, or like another guy saying like, cut the shit, screw your head on. It cuts through in a way that women unfortunately often can't. Research in social psychology shows that in-group criticism, when it comes from someone who is inside your own group, it carries more weight. A man challenging another man doesn't just interrupt the harmful cycle. It redefines the norm within that group and it signals that, you know, respect and equality for women, that's the standard, not the exception, not just something that you perform when you're actually around women.
这让人感到不舒服。我也曾有过这样的时刻，我没有说出我本该说出口的话，但这只是默默地在强化一种正在伤害你同胞兄弟的信仰体系。当另一个男人站出来时，无论是像一句简单的“这不好笑”那样，还是像另一个家伙说“别扯淡了，把脑子放清醒点”。这种干预所产生的穿透力，是不幸的是女性往往无法做到的。社会心理学研究表明，内部群体的批评——当它来自于你自身群体内部的人时——具有更大的分量。一个男人挑战另一个男人，不仅打破了有害的循环。它重新定义了该群体内部的规范，并传递出一个信号：即对女性的尊重和平等，是标准，而不是例外，绝不仅仅是在你真正有女性在场时才表现出来的东西。
Number five, and I think this is the most crucial one, we need to stop pretending that men and women can't be friends. And I know if you're a woman, you're probably hearing this and being like, oh, like, I know the feeling, right? I know why you're probably rolling your eyes. You're like, Yeah, but I try to be friends with men and they just want to date me. No, we need to make this completely platonic from both sides. This is bringing me back to an earlier point I made about the fact that male loneliness, yes, it is caused by men not having male friends. It's also caused by the fact that when they see a woman,
第五点，我认为这也是最关键的一点，我们需要停止假装男人和女人不能成为朋友。我知道如果你是一个女性，你听到这里时可能会想：噢，我懂这种感觉，对吧？我知道你为什么可能在翻白眼了。你会想：是的，但我试图和男人做朋友，而他们只想和我约会。不，我们需要让这种关系在双方之间都保持纯粹的柏拉图式友谊。这让我想到了我之前提出的一个观点，即男性的孤独，是的，是因为男性没有男性朋友。这也是因为当他们看到一个女性时，
that's either someone they want to date or they can dismiss, or maybe a family member. And oh my gosh, do they miss out. They miss out when they have that mindset. Imagine thinking that you can only be friends with 50% of the people in the world compared to 100% of people. You're already limiting yourself here. Like, you're already starting from a less favorable position
要么是他们想约会的人，要么是可以被他们无视的人，或者也许是一个家庭成员。哦天哪，他们错过了多少东西啊。当他们抱着这种心态时，他们错过了太多。想象一下，你认为自己只能和世界上50%的人做朋友，而不是100%的人。你在这里就已经在限制自己了。在应对孤独这件事情上，你从一开始就处于一个
when it comes to tackling loneliness. You already have less options. I did a full episode on this a while back titled Can Men and Women Be Friends? And I think I know the answer is yes. They very much can. And they very much should be. I think this would go a long way in all. also humanizing women for some of these men who have unfortunately fallen into a bit of a male-centric
不那么有利的地位。你的选择已经变少了。不久前我曾就此做过一整期播客，题为《男人和女人能成为朋友吗？》，我认为答案是肯定的。他们完全可以。而且他们非常应该成为朋友。我认为这对于打破某些男性不幸陷入的、以男性为中心的
echo chamber. Number six, we need to continue to encourage people to talk about their mental health and to reduce stigma around to saying, I'm super lonely, I'm super sad, I'm having a rough time. As I kind of finish up this episode, I want to reiterate, loneliness sucks, whoever you are. The stigma we face around mental health is actively hurting people and shaming them into becoming further isolated and silent, not getting the support that is available to them, not being open. And let's be real, it really, really hurts people. I also think a rising tide lifts all ships. It's not a gendered thing. We need to start having conversations openly about mental health. And we need to start by doing it ourselves.
回音室效应，进而将女性“去脸谱化”恢复为有血有肉的人，将会产生深远的影响。第六点，我们需要继续鼓励人们谈论他们的心理健康，并减少说出“我超级孤独，我超级难过，我正经历一段艰难时期”这番话所伴随的污名。在我结束这期播客之际，我想重申：孤独很糟糕，无论你是谁。我们在心理健康上面对的污名正在切实地伤害人们，并让他们感到羞耻，从而进一步陷入孤立和沉默，无法获得可用的支持，无法敞开心扉。说实话，这真的真的很伤人。我也认为“水涨船高”。这不是一个性别问题。我们需要开始公开地谈论心理健康。并且我们需要从自己做起。
Be brave enough to just answer the question. How are you doing? With honesty. Because it has a chain reaction. It invites people to share. For my male listeners, even if it's just the men in your family, your cousins, your dad, your grandfather, your brothers,
勇敢一点去回答这个问题。你最近过得怎么样？带着诚实去回答。因为这会产生连锁反应。它会邀请其他人也来分享。对于我的男性听众来说，哪怕只是你家族里的男性，你的表兄弟、你的爸爸、你的爷爷、你的兄弟们，
share with them, ask them how they are. Check in. It might feel awkward. It might feel hard. I actually think sometimes the best things feel uncomfortable at first because that discomfort is a sign that something needs to happen and something needs to change. Alrighty, as we wrap this episode up, I want to thank you again for coming into this episode with an open mind.
与他们分享，问问他们过得怎么样。嘘寒问暖。这可能会让人感到尴尬。这可能会让人觉得很难。我其实认为，有时候最棒的事情一开始都会让人感到不舒服，因为这种不舒服恰恰是一个信号，表明有什么事情需要发生，有什么事情需要改变。好了，随着这期节目的尾声，我要再次感谢大家带着开放的心态收听这期节目。
And if you're going to comment something down below, please keep it civilized. I will, like, I don't want to see anyone being nasty. I don't want to see anyone being mean. I definitely don't want to see anyone calling me fat, as has happened in the past, or anyone calling anyone, anything rude, to keep it civil. But I do want to see the conversation keep going down there, because there's definitely things I've missed. There's definitely perspectives that I just haven't thought of.
如果你要在下方评论区留言，请保持文明。我不想看到任何人表现得恶劣。我不想看到任何人表现得刻薄。我绝对不想看到任何人像过去那样骂我胖，或者任何人对任何人说任何粗鲁的话，请保持文明。但我确实希望看到讨论在下面继续进行，因为肯定有些东西是我漏掉的。肯定有些视角是我根本没有想到的。
So if you have a perspective or an opinion, please, please share it below. I would love to hear from you. And I hope that this episode has illuminated some things for you. Share it with a friend, if it has. Share it with your guy friends, your female friends, your friends of all genders, your old friends, your new friends, whoever it is, and see what their thoughts are as well.
所以如果你有什么视角或观点，请务必在下方分享。我很想听听你们的看法。我希望这期节目能为你带来一些启发。如果确实如此，请把它分享给朋友。分享给你的男性朋友、女性朋友、所有性别的朋侪、老朋友、新朋友，无论是谁，去看看他们是怎么想的。
Make sure as well that you are following us on Instagram at that psychology podcast. If you want to learn more about this topic and also see more of what we're doing on the psychology of your 20s, I also want to thank our researcher Libby Colbert for her contributions to this episode and for pushing me to do this episode. I really, really appreciate her. We wouldn't be able to do it without her. And make sure that you're following along wherever you're listening, Spotify, Apple Podcast, the IHart Radio app.
同时，请确保在Instagram上关注我们，账号是 that psychology podcast。如果你想了解更多关于这个话题的信息，并查看更多我们在《你二十多岁的心理学》（The Psychology of Your 20s）中做的事情。我还要感谢我们的研究员莉比·科尔伯特（Libby Colbert）对这期节目的贡献，以及她督促我做这期节目。我真的很感激她。没有她，我们根本无法完成这一切。无论你在哪里收听，请确保关注我们，Spotify、苹果播客、IHeart Radio应用。
Give us a five-star review if you feel called to do so. This won't be the last time we talk about this. So I can't wait to keep the conversation going. But until next time, until our next episode, stay safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. Take care of yourself as well. Talk about your mental health as well. That's my final reminder. And we will talk very, very soon.
如果你愿意的话，请给我们一个五星好评。我们讨论这个话题不会是最后一次，所以我迫不及待地想继续我们的对话。但在下一次、我们的下一期节目之前，请注意安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一些。也要照顾好自己，谈谈你的心理健康。这是我最后的提醒。我们很快就会再聊。
2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at a podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me.
2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身和培养抗挫力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你会以一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的自己迎来蜕变。收听《2%》。在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方搜索“2%”。在《Look Back at》播客节目中，从1979年开始，这对我和说是个重大时刻。
84 was big to me. I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year.
84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·杰伊。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及我们最喜爱的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? listening to learn the hard way with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with.
我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或任何你收听播客的地方收听《Look Back At It》。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？正在收听由你们最喜爱的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间旨在探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在其他任何地方都不太安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着铠甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。
And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
而且，仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须这么做。在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你曾两次篡改这个特定的测试结果，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。
Greg Gillespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens. finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast
格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我太震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。收听《Love Trapped》播客
on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或任何你获取播客的地方。这是一档 iHeart 播客。纯人工保证。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。